Speaker 1: I want to play a clip for you guys
today, which I believe is a perfect example
of how Democrats should be dealing with these
neo reactionary Republicans in the House of
Representatives and in the Senate. You know
what? One of the conversations we've had over
the last few years is that even though the right
has absolutely no minimum standard whatsoever for
what they want, what they won't do, what they're
not willing to do. We on the left shouldn't sink
to their level in the sense of telling straight
up lies, fabricating imaginary social issues,
employing horrifying double standards of personal
attacks, all of these different things. But what
Democrats should appeal to is the public's sort
of sense of justice and emotions in order to get
them to understand the stakes of so many things.
This is really one for the ages. Congressman Jamie
Raskin, a Democrat who I'm a fan of, I like
Jamie Raskin. I've talked about him before.
He ripped Marjorie Taylor GREENE to shreds
after during a floor debate supposedly about
Ukraine. It's supposedly about the brutal
invasion of Ukraine by Vladimir Putin. She said
nothing about it. She instead talked about the
southern border and made a whole bunch of other
completely fact free claims. And Jamie Raskin
takes her to task. And I wish more Democrats
in the House day in and day out, spoke
about their extremist Republican colleagues
in this way, maybe it could help them hold the
House in November. Take a look at this tact.
Speaker 3: It's a shame. It's a tragedy.
I yield back the remainder of reserve.
Speaker 4: Gentleman, gentleman's time
has expired. Gentleman from Pennsylvania
reserves. Gentleman from Maryland's
recognized. Mr. Speaker, the United States
of America just witnessed. Witnessed the most
astonishing spectacle. We are here to debate.
Aid to the people of Ukraine, defending
themselves against a massive invasion
by Vladimir Putin and his army. Right. Then the
minority puts up the distinguished gentlelady
from Georgia who does not mention Ukraine once.
Speaker 1: And by the way, yes, I believe his
use of the term distinguished gentlelady
about Marjorie Taylor GREENE. I believe it.
It's tongue in cheek.
Speaker 4: She does not mention
the thousands of Ukrainian civilians who've been
slaughtered by Putin's army. She does not mention
more than 100 Ukrainian children who've been
shot and killed by the Ukrainian army. Instead,
she talks about a massive invasion at the border,
a massive invasion which their own speakers have
said today. Hundreds of thousands of people have
been apprehended in. That's very different from a
military invasion. The one in Ukraine, of course,
the general lady's not going to talk about that.
She had a lot to say the other day when she
heckled me continuously. When I came to the floor,
it was like the Rocky Horror Picture Show in here
with her chanting about the Russia hoax and Russia
this and Russia that. Now, she had the opportunity
to tell the world what her views about Russia are.
I put them out there exactly what she has said.
She said that the aid that the taxpayers of
America are sending to the people of Ukraine to
defend themselves against Vladimir Putin and the
Russian army falls into the hands of Nazis. I
want to see your proof. Where's your evidence?
She talks about neo-Nazis. Does my
minority believe that our allies in NAITO
who are trying to defend the people of
Ukraine are Nazis? Has it come to this?
General lady talked about a massive
invasion. We had a massive invasion
of our own chamber, and she continued to
be a cheerleader for the insurrection.
Speaker 1: This is exactly why I keep talking
about Jamie Raskin as someone that I would support
for president, of course, depending on who else is
running and depending on what his platform would
be. But in principle, someone I would support for
president. He's a constitutional law professor. He
actually knows the Constitution. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE loves to talk about the Constitution.
Madison Cawthorn loves to claim that he's
defending the Constitution. They don't know a damn
thing about it. This is actually a constitutional
law professor. Raskin was a strong progressive
activist when he was in the Maryland Senate. He
actually worked with Republicans and moderate
Democrats and got things done. He sponsored bills
to get rid of the death penalty in Maryland,
to establish legal guidelines for corporations
to prevent them from raping and pillaging the
resources of the state for their gain. He worked
he was on the he was actually a board member of
FairVote, which is an interesting organization.
He sponsored the first bill in the country for the
national popular vote. I've talked about so much,
which would be a way to get rid of the Electoral
College without actually having to change the
Constitution. He has this law, marijuana reform,
all these different things. This is what has
to be done. We need a guy like Raskin. Talking
about them as the extremists that they are
wanting everybody to have. Health care is not
the left equivalent of supporting a coup. They
have nothing to do with each other. And the level
of extremism that we are seeing from the right
requires and demands people like Raskin, who can
speak in this way. Now, Raskin's not the only guy
I've talked about, other people I like as well.
But Democrats need to be talking like this
more frequently, and I'm glad to see him do it.